tonight in just a moment i'll have a
special message
you're not going to want to miss this i
promise you won't want to miss it
for former president barack hussein
obama
that's straight ahead but first after
more than 100 days in
office one overreaching theme is
dominating now
sippy cup joe's administration and that
theme
is complete weakness weakness abroad
weakness at home
a weak commander-in-chief who believes
that full-scale appeasement even of our
enemies will bring about peace in our
time
now joe's cowardly response to russia's
hack of the colonial pipeline
it is beyond embarrassing it's also
self-destruct
destructive and not only did biden give
vladimir
a free pass on russians hacking the
colonial pipeline
but then five days later get this joe
rewarded his pal vladimir
by removing trump error sanctions on
what was a
key russian pipeline that helps
our allies uh in germany and elsewhere
in europe and not only is america first
strategies gone
completely dead energy independent it's
is now
gone that's dead but now joe has
literally adopted
oh vladimir putin and russia first
policies
and to make putin and russia rich again
closing down our pipeline and giving a
waiver
to vladimir putin to build his and it
turns out i guess at the real russia
collusion
um yeah that would be leading democrats
remember obama tell vladimir i'll have
more flexibility after the election
hillary clinton paying for the dirty
russian disinformation
dossier then used as the basis to spy on
a presidential candidate
and a president with premeditated fraud
on a fisa court
and then don't forget hunter biden's 3.5
millions he got
with a from a russian oligarch the first
lady of moscow
and now joe destroys in america
high-paying career jobs in the energy
sector
by shutting down our pipeline with the
stroke of a pen
ending our energy independence allowing
a waiver
so putin can build his pipeline to
supply
energy to our allies now when it comes
to russia joe gave the green light two
thumbs up
here we go one of our biggest
geopolitical foes
who relies on oil and gas in russia
to fund all their proxy wars all the
nefarious activities they've been
involved in including sabotaging america
at every chance
and it's even worse than that because
now the same can also be said about
sippy cup joe and iran as joe's working
hard
again to lift sanctions against the
muellers in iran
you know that want to wipe israel wipe
america off the face of the planet
remember last time they gave 150 billion
and let's see
cash you know the country uh of the
currency on the tarmacs to mueller's and
iran
so the question is why would mr sippy
cup warm milky
bedtime story joe be so willing to lift
sanctions on russian oil and iranian oil
all while limiting american oil
destroying american jobs
uh american energy independence right
here at home
well we can answer with one word joe
appeasement two words appeasement is the
main word
appeasement for our enemies abroad
appeasement for joe's radical base here
at home
now we're watching this play out in
israel first biden reinstated america
funding to the palestinians with no
strings attached
donald trump had cut it off soon after
hamas
well they begin launching thousands of
iranian-supplied rockets
right into israeli cities now joe
apparently wants israel to stop
defending
itself with a unilateral cease-fire
what would he do if those those rockets
were being fired into american cities
in other words that word one word
appeasement
now meanwhile back here at home joe is
also appeasing his radical
anti-semitic base one example
congresswoman
rashida talib obsessively hating israel
and of course the jewish people who live
there she once retweeted a statement
calling for israel's elimination earlier
this year she held a fundraiser
with a notorious anti-semite who once
referred to jews
as satanic she also openly complained
about the biden administration's
decision
to appoint a jewish secretary of state
to leave apparently worried that
blinking the secretary of state
would be too pro-israel because he's
jewish
and worst of all to leave once talked
about i don't know how this happened
her calming feeling she gets when she
thinks about
the holocaust now the statement goes on
to explain in more context
but never once did she mention the
millions of jewish people
that were slaughtered in the holocaust
take a listen
there's a kind of a calming feeling i
always tell folks when i think
of the holocaust and the tragedy of the
holocaust
and the fact that it was my ancestors
palestinians
who lost their land and some lost their
lives their livelihood the human dignity
their existence in many ways have been
wiped out and some people's passport i
mean just
all of it was in the name of trying to
create a safe haven truth for jews
post the holocaust i love the fact that
it was my ancestors that provided that
right in many ways but they did it in a
way that
took their human dignity away right and
it was forced
on them clearly talib is a maniac
she's an anti-semite spends most of her
time obsessing over the state of israel
she should not be in any elected office
frankly
ever yesterday she meets biden on the
tarmac in michigan
according to numerous reports chewing
him out
for him supporting our closest ally only
democracy in the region in the middle
east
and their right to defend itself the way
we would defend ourselves
remember the same woman who had to be
forcibly removed from a trump rally back
in 2015
this is not a rational peace-loving
individual
but biden gives her 10 minutes on the
tarmac
refuses to condemn the anti-semites in
his party
same goes for pelosi same goes for
schumer and it's clear
now more than ever the radical green new
deal socialist squad
they now rule the democratic party along
with
bolshevik bernie the honeymoon in the
former soviet union
praised castro and daniel ortega and
chavez
its leaders cower before this radical
squad
the president even he prays on talib
during his speech
after just hours after that encounter on
the tarmac perhaps he was intimidated
joe biden is beyond anything else weak
and he's spineless clearly afraid of the
radical squad
and pretty much does everything they say
what el what else would you expect from
a guy who can be blown over three times
so they tell us
from a gust of wind and today during a
rare appearance outside the white house
biden embarrassed himself yet again in a
speech that was frankly
yeah painful to watch take a look
i brought with me a former academy grad
who now serves as my coast guard miller
lieutenant commander janet
now i'm going to embarrass her janet
mccrone of the class of 2007.
well the name that you know we're
endowed by the
the thing oh you know the thing endowed
by our creator
god the creator of everything joe
unfortunately it got even worse at one
point biden attempted to deliver a joke
got his words mixed up and after nobody
laughed
well joey became very angry he wanted a
sippy cup take a look
i can only assume that you will enjoy
educating your family about how the
coast guard is quote
the hard nucleus around the navy forms
in times of war are
quite you're a really dull class
come on man is the sun getting to you
i would think you'd have an opportunity
when i say that about the navy to clap
but
being here together
walk in the side being here together is
a victory in and of itself
we did get the signature come on man now
we know
why his team orders him not to take
questions
and true to form biden's attempted joke
was not an original
but unlike joe president ronald reagan
well about the same age as joe
at that time in his presidency he could
actually deliver a punchline for
comparison
let's just take a look at president
reagan and biden back to back
we'll let you decide if you see a
difference
my coast guard aides have been excellent
one of them taught me that
and i quote the coast guard is that hard
nucleus about which the navy forms in
time of war
i can only assume that you will enjoy
educating your family about
how the coast guard is quote the hard
nucleus around
the navy forms in times of war
you are quite you're a really dull class
all right come on man come on man you're
the dull president that could barely
string a few sentences together
piece of advice joey a uh stop insulting
our soldiers
when they don't laugh at your terrible
jokes you might remember this
and i want you to know notwithstanding
what you may hear about me
i have incredibly good judgment one
i married jill and two i appointed
johnson to the academy i just want you
to know that
it's flattered
that guy looks a little better than that
guy today anyway i have another piece of
advice joey
stop telling jokes you're not funny you
never will be
and you're as bad as most of the lame
late-night shows on television now
also you might want to invest in some
golf lessons if you're going to play
see look at your screen right there
watch that very closely biden
struggles on the golf course um
in that case the ball went backwards
i don't have time to play a lot of golf
joe played a few rounds of my day
but i never hit a ball backwards hit it
out middle left hit it right
but never backwards more seriously joe's
also reportedly having trouble with vice
president kamala harris
a new book is out claiming that dr li
the first lady jill biden said that
harris can go
bleep herself after that debate when
harris called out biden's history of
racism in the first democratic debate
matter of fact she went silent after
that don't worry we'll carry the torch
and remind people for you kamala
now meanwhile vice president harris
she's getting criticized for hiding her
tremendous wealth
behind a family trust this article on
foxnews.com quote the trust
assets are not reportable
effectively obscuring some of the vice
presidents holding from public view
this clearly violates the hollow ethics
pledge that she and joe made on the
campaign trail
but remember bulls don't apply to
democrats only republicans
get charged with lying to congress
they're the only ones lucky enough to
get 28 guys in tactical gear
guns drawn pre-dawn raids frog men in
the backyard
cnn cameras they're exactly at the right
moment to capture the event
only they get in trouble for process
crimes like lying to congress
not democrats for example democrats
they're obsessed with something they
call
well institutional racism we hear it all
the time look what's happening in
chicago
mayor lori lightfoot i kind of call her
lightweight considering she doesn't seem
to have any interest in stopping
the violence 46 people shot this past
weekend
in chicago by the way quick quick exam
quiz do you know the names of any of
them anyway she now instituted a policy
banning white people they're not allowed
to interview her
only people of color the mayor's office
will now only grant
one-on-one interviews with quote black
or brown reporters because lightfoot
believes there are too many white people
working for the city's news outlets
not only is this official policy
obviously racist but the mayor
uh well wouldn't be the mayor's time be
better served
looking for ways to stop the shootings
every weekend in her city
yeah again nearly 50 people this weekend
shot
anyway mayor lightweight is more
concerned with the amount of
white people working where the chicago
tribune at a local tv news station
this is really pathetic and sad hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else